from the very beginning of English
settlement in North America the contrast
between the southern colonies and the
northern colonies was stark things
didn't improve much when the 13 colonies
rebelled in 1776 and became an
independent nation tensions over slavery
flared during the crafting of the US
Constitution and repeatedly during the
19th century when compromises in 1820
and 1850 barely maintained the fragile
balance between northern and southern
states but in 1860 the wheels finally
came off and the southern states seceded
from the Union starting the Civil War
after more than 80 years of compromise
why did the differences between the
north and the south
finally become irreconcilable in the
1850s in other videos we've traced the
differences and similarities between the
north and south from the colonial era
until the late 1840s in terms of
economics social structure and commonly
held ideas about slavery let's revisit
those comparisons for the years
immediately leading up to the Civil War
and see if we can identify why the
conflict intensified in the 1850s the
difference between the economies of the
north and south began way back at the
outset of colonization in North America
when the cold climate of the north
prevented large-scale plantation
agriculture instead the northern economy
centered on trade and manufacturing the
First and Second Industrial Revolution
turned the northern economy into one
based on factories where men women and
children worked for long hours sometimes
in dangerous conditions in the 1840s the
potato famine and Ireland and
revolutions in Europe prompted many
Irish and German immigrants to come to
northern cities in search of factory
jobs they even though most factory
workers in the north struggled to make
ends meet there was some opportunity for
social mobility to climb the economic
ladder and therefore the north also had
a growing middle class in the mid 19th
century many in the lower-class held out
hope that they could move out west and
start a small family farm in order to
become financially stable so to
recap the class structure in the north
looked kind of like this a large working
class of laborers many of them
immigrants a middle class of managers
and small business owners and a small
upper class of factory owners bankers
and successful merchants in the south
cultivating valuable cash crops to sell
on the national and international
markets had always been the center of
the economy cotton had slowly replaced
tobacco as the number-one crop in the
south and American cotton plantations
were producing nearly 70% of the world's
cotton supply by 1860 with agriculture
working out so well for plantation
owners there was no need to
industrialize as in the north all the
labor on plantations was done by
enslaved people who had no hope of
improving their lot in life except by
running away there was also a large
number of poor white farmers who owned
no slaves and a few modest planters that
owned fewer than 10 enslaved people
despite the popular myth of gigantic
plantations across the South only 1/10
of a percent of slaveholders owned more
than 100 people the class system in the
South was extremely rigid and
aristocratic not far off from a medieval
feudal society with a handful of wealthy
white families dominating in each
southern state wealth was measured in
the south by the number of enslaved
people a planter owned poorer White's
aspired to buy enslaved people and
become plantation owners themselves but
their prospects of doing so were pretty
slim by the 1850s growing cotton quickly
depleted the soil and so both large
plantation owners and whites who dreamed
of becoming large plantation owners
looked to the West for new lands to
cultivate in order to expand the cotton
Kingdom in short the class structure in
the south looked a little like this a
large permanent underclass of enslaved
laborers with non-slaveholding White's
above them in rights and an economic
power then there was a small number of
planters who owned a few enslaved people
and at the very top was a tiny fraction
of large planters who owned more than
100 enslaved people so how did these
economic differences lead to tension
well first there were tensions over
whether the economic policy of the
federal government promoted agriculture
or manufacturing things like tariffs and
the expansion of the railroad turned
into bitter fights over whether the
government was prioritizing the needs of
one section or the other and then there
was westward expansion both northerners
and southerners looked to the West for
their future economic opportunities and
both sides suspected the other of trying
to suppress their paths to social
mobility the ideologies of the north and
south also diverged sharply in the 1850s
in the north most White's didn't object
to slavery as it existed in the south
but worried about the potential
expansion of slavery to the West the
Free Soil movement aimed to preserve
Western lands for small white farmers
there was also a growing sense among
northerners that the south had too much
power in the federal government thanks
to the three-fifths compromise which
granted southern states representation
in Congress for 60% of its
disenfranchised enslaved population in
addition to its white population this
was a fair charge to make many events of
the 1850s like the Fugitive Slave Act
which compelled northern whites to
assist in capturing runaway slaves the
kansas-nebraska Act which reopened the
possibility of allowing slavery north of
the Missouri Compromise line and the
Supreme Court's decision in the case
Dred Scott vs. Sanford which claimed
that African Americans weren't citizens
convinced northerners that what they
called the slave power had come to
dominate government consequently the
abolition movement which called for the
immediate end of slavery everywhere grew
considerably more mainstream in the
1850s writers like Harriet Beecher Stowe
author of the influential abolitionist
novel Uncle Tom's Cabin activists like
Frederick Douglas who had escaped from
slavery and toured the North lecturing
about its evils and vigilantes like John
Brown who led deadly raids on
slaveholders
dramatised the moral evil of slavery to
a growing audience in this time period
in contrast to the north white
southerners believed they had the
constitution on their side and that
northern attempts to limit the expansion
of slavery constituted an assault on
their liberty in addition white
Southerners began to craft a proactive
defense of the institution of slavery in
the 1850s instead of treating slavery
like the South's embarrassing but
necessary peculiar institution as they
had in the past
southern commentators began to frame
slavery as a positive good they pointed
to the conditions of immigrants and
northern factories who might be injured
in an accident at work and then be fired
for no longer being productive slave
owners argued that they treated their
enslaved laborers better than northern
factory owners treated their wage slaves
southern sociologist George Fitzhugh
wrote two books arguing that slavery was
preferable to the kill-or-be-killed
environment of unbridled capitalism and
that poor whites should be enslaved in
addition to people of African descent in
order to protect them from being eaten
alive in the free market in looking at
these economic social and ideological
differences between the North and South
it's clear that by the 1850s there was
really a clash of cultures going on what
the United States be an agricultural
nation or an industrial one one where
anyone no matter their color or place of
birth could climb the social ladder
or one where just a few deserve to enjoy
all the blessings of liberty in 1860
these questions would propel the country
into civil war